tout commence quand plusieurs caméras
donc la caméra embarquée d'une voiture
de police de Las Vegas ont filmé cet
objet cet ovni comme on dit tombant du
ciel regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je dis que c'est évidemment un film
intrigant il faudra attendre le résultat
de l'enquête pour savoir ce qui a été
filmé des films comme ça il y en a
évidemment depuis fort longtemps puisque
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
avoir des caméras notamment via les
smartphones
justement Jean-Claude moi j'ai une
question de poser parce que à chaque
fois on voit des vidéos on dit qu'il va
y avoir une enquête et on entend plus
jamais parler de l'enquête c'est très
vrai ce que vous dites
je vais vous citer un exemple
extraordinaire qui est l'histoire de la
centrale de Fessenheim en 2019 vous avez
des gendarmes et des gardes qui sont
autour de la centrale nucléaire de
Fessenheim et il voit vers 22h plusieurs
ovnis dont un qui faisait plus de 20
mètres de diamètre et qui était
au-dessus de la et qui restait 45
minutes la sécurité militaire est venue
dès le lendemain matin et la saisit
toutes les vidéos alors vous qui avez le
bras long vous pouvez peut-être essayer
de la récupérer parce que ça c'est une
véritable vidéo d'objets volants non
identité
derrière il y a simplement le directeur
de la centrale de Fessenheim comme
c'était énorme comme témoignage il y
avait des des gendarmes il y avait des
garde assermentées il a fait un petit
communiqué disant la centrale de
Fessenheim a été survolée par un aéronef
inconnu l'enquête est en cours on attend
le résultat de l'enquête et on attend
toujours les résultats à mon avis c'est
ensuite l'appel d'une famille qui pose
énormément de questions regardez leurs
témoignages
j'aperçois une silhouette de 2 mètres 50
et à côté il y en a une autre avec des
gros yeux qui nous regardent et ils sont
toujours là
ok c'est où
dans le fond de mon jardin ils sont
combien je vous jure c'est pas une
blague donc ils sont deux dans votre
jardin
c'est ça ils sont énormes il faut
presque 2 mètres 50 3 mètres
je sais pas mais on dirait des aliens je
peux pas l'expliquer
on est terrifié
à 100% qu'ils sont pas humains
tout ça ce qu'ils disent c'est c'est
plausible alors ce n'est pas un
témoignage unique on est recueilli
moi-même au cours des 50 années au cours
desquelles j'ai fait des enquêtes je me
souviens d'un professeur des écoles qui
faisait du camping
en plein été avec son mari il était
minuit écart à peu près c'était dans le
sud de la France et puis elle était
dehors comme ça le regardait les étoiles
et puis d'un seul coup il m'entend
marcher dans l'herbe derrière elle et
elle se retourne elle voit un espèce de
robot qui se découpait sur le ciel qui
faisait à peu près 2 mètres de haut avec
des yeux légèrement luminescents et à ce
moment là elle a eu une peur mais elle
m'a dit cette peur n'était absolument
pas normal elle était émise par cette
espèce de robot le mari qui était dans
l'attente et qui n'avait rien vu était
également et la plongé dans l'attente et
puis ils se sont serrés l'un contre
l'autre comme ça pendant que cette
espèce de choses est passée et puis
quand ça s'est éloigné la peur s'est
atténuée ils sont sortis il y avait plus
rien mais elle me dit je sais ce que
j'ai vu je ne suis pas folle et elle a
jamais voulu que son nom soit cité Nice
celui de son mari parce que ils étaient
dans l'enseignement alors cette famille
s'est filmée juste après avoir vu l'ovni
ils ont voulu aller voir de plus près et
regardez ils étaient pas bien c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout halloween c'est
extrêmement sérieux et moi j'ai une
question pour Jean-Claude comme par
hasard on voit que ça se passe à Las
Vegas dans le Nevada là où on dit que
peut-être les Américains ont réceptionné
des ovnis qui se sont crashés pour
expertiser et en agrémenter leur
matériel militaire est-ce que finalement
les extraterrestres sont pas en train de
rentrer chez eux et de retrouver ceux
qui sont déjà au Nevada alors il y a une
explication tout à fait plausible c'est
pour comprendre un peu toutes ces
histoires d'OVNI qui touchent l'ensemble
des pays du monde la Chine l'Amérique du
Sud l'Australie tous c'est qu'il voyage
dans le temps c'est le thème de
l'enquête qui vient de paraître il y a
trois jours juste avant ce week-end
j'explique avec
Patrick Marquet qui est un physicien de
haut niveau qui a travaillé d'ailleurs
avec le prix Nobel de Breuil Patrick
marquer c'est un bon temps bien sûr
il a fait les plus hautes études nous
publions d'ailleurs des photos d'OVNI
jugées authentiques et pour répondre à
votre question s'ils ont la capacité de
voyager dans le temps ils ont des portes
qui permettent des portes dans
l'espace-temps qui permettent d'arriver
n'importe où chez nous que ce soit Las
Vegas ou que ce soit dans le sud de la
banque qui sont le voyage dans le temps
qui paraît absurde j'en avais parlé la
dernière fois sur le plateau de Cyril
Hanouna
on explique que non seulement il est pas
absurde mais nous démontrons qui les
faisable maintenant avec les dernières
connaissances scientifiques nous
montrons des photos d'ovnis jugées
authentiques et où on voit qu'il y a une
manipulation de l'espace-temps
c'est passionnant oui moi ce qui me sert
à chaque fois c'est
le peu de chance qu'on à chaque fois les
gens qui voient des phénomènes
extraterrestres ils ont leur caméra tout
le temps ils sont aux toilettes avec
leur téléphone ils filment ce qu'ils
mangent et là il y a des extraits des
extraterrestres devant eux ils les films
pas ah bah alors faut arrêter de se
dans notre gueule on
extraterrestre le mec de 2 mètres 50
avec des gros yeux on le voit devant
leur maison regarde il confirme tous
leurs témoignages ils ont tous vu la
même chose
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu c'était une
énorme créature elle faisait au moins
trois mètres
avec quelque chose tombait du ciel donc
c'est assez étrange
vous avez vu quelque chose tomber dans
le fond de votre jardin c'est ça ils ont
vu un gros un gros un gros truc avec de
la lumière
question gentil s'il vous plaît
Jean-Claude qui vient de dire là parce
qu'il y a plein de gens qui vont dire ça
et il y en a il y en a certains nombres
quand je dis qu'il y en a un certain
nombre je parle de de ceux qui habitent
la planète Terre qui s'entendent les
terriens et qui oblige ceux qui comme
moi au départ ne croyait absolument pas
tout ça
tout ça non seulement j'y croyais pas
mais j'étais très heureuse c'était
bêtises il y a un mot un peu plus
vulgaire donc je n'y croyais absolument
pas c'est quand je me suis plongé dans
le dossier des ovnis quand j'ai
interviewé le ministre de la Défense de
l'époque Monsieur Robert Gallet
m'attendant à ce qu'il me disent mais
non monsieur bourré excusez-moi mais moi
je suis le patron des armées et je peux
vous dire que dans tous les dossiers
militaires que j'ai recueilli depuis 50
ans il y a pas un seul cas crédible
devenu il m'a dit exactement l'inverse
c'était Monsieur Robert Gallet il m'a
dit il y a des pilotes de chasse qui ont
essayé de poursuivre des ovnis d'autres
qui étaient suivis par des ovnis il y a
eu des observé par des patrouilles de
l'armée par des patrouilles de gendarmes
etc vous avez le cas de Valensole qui
est un cas extraordinaire il y a un film
qui sort d'ailleurs en ce moment et qui
raconte l'histoire de valençale un cas
d'atterrissage en plein jour avec
Monsieur Maurice masque qui voit cette
OVNI à 6h30 du matin il est déjà dans
son champ de lavande c'est dans le sud
de la France et puis il s'approche de
l'ovni il comprend pas ce qu'il voit il
s'intéresse pas aux ovnis on est en 1955
il voit un truc qui croit d'abord que
c'est une voiture des Parisiens qui sont
venus se garer dans son champ de lavande
il est pas content pivoie deux petits
bonhommes deux petits bonhommes qui fait
1m10 1m20 de haut
dans la journée et donc
il s'approche et l'un des petits
bonhommes prend à son côté une sorte de
tube le dirige sur monsieur masse qui
est paralysé pendant 10 minutes les deux
petits bonhommes remontent dans l'ovni
l'ovni décolle il y a des traces
d'atterrissages l'armée fait une enquête
la gendarmerie fait une enquête les
services secrets font une en et 50 ans
plus tard on sait toujours pas sorti
mais j'ai envie de vous croire et je
voudrais savoir par rapport à justement
l'existence de ces extraterrestres
pourquoi vous nous dites que les
enquêtes n'aboutissent jamais quel
intérêt de nous le cacher pourquoi on a
bien sûr la vérité en fait alors il y a
plusieurs réponses à votre question
d'abord je ne suis pas évidemment la
tâcher de presse des éventuels
extraterrestres j'essaye de comprendre
je note avec une grande précision et un
grand intérêt les déclarations qui
étaient faites par des gens qui savent
donc cité Monsieur Robert Gallet quand
il meurt dans son bureau ministère des
armées il avait peut-être 250 rapports
secret très sucré ce très défense vous
avez également le ministre canadien de
la défense qui est mort il y a quelque
temps et qui avait fait des déclarations
et même je crois un livre ou deux sur
les Objets Volants Non Identifié parce
qu'il les a vu lui de ses yeux vu et il
dit ça existe et cetera vous avez Rahim
échec qui est un éminent
une fille qui se réélient qui a 85 ans
maintenant général de salle décorer
trois fois de la plus haute distinction
israélienne et qui a dit en 2021 c'est
pas vieux il a dit les extraterrestres
sont parmi nous ce qui répondrait à la
question de Cyril Hanouna et évidemment
un certain nombre de gouvernements de la
terre savent qu'ils sont où ils sont
est-ce qu'ils font d'accord donc ce qui
nous gouverne ils savent qu'ils sont là
donc Emmanuel Macron
tous ceux qui nous gouvernent savent
qu'ils sont là mais je pense qu'il y a
un certain nombre de hauts responsables
dans les services de renseignement des
grands pays de ce monde les États-Unis
l'Australie le Canada Israël évidemment
la Chine qui qui connaissent la rupture
Biden il le sait qu'il y a des
extraterrestres
il est très fatigué
mais comment ça se fait qu'on envoie de
plus en plus des trucs comme ça là alors
une fois par an Jean-Claude maintenant
tu viens de voir toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines
il est possible qu'il ait une ouverture
de d'une porte sur l'espace-temps et que
ils aient décidé de venir plus
massivement comme ils sont venus en 1954
en 1954 il y a une très grande vague
d'observation sur l'Europe en général et
sur la France en particulier il y avait
jusqu'à 30 à 44 d'observations par jour
à la fin de 1954 et puis ça a disparu ça
ne peut se comprendre que avec le voyage
dans le temps si le voyage donc tu peux
rapper le voyage dans le temps parce que
là donc tu dis que là en ce moment il y
a des promos pour les ovnis ils viennent
plus souvent ils ont trouvé la porte en
ce moment ils viennent ils viennent plus
souvent chez nous alors d'abord le
voyage dans le temps maintenant nous
savons que c'est possible nous faisons
la démonstration dans ce livre avec un
certain nombre de calculs qui sont pour
ceux qui au niveau Matsu maspé à la fin
du livre mais je vous rassure tout de
suite et 90 % du livre se lit quelque
chose niveau intellectuel et donc nous
avons que maintenant le voyage dans le
temps est une possibilité qui s'offre à
nous et que avec les ordinateurs
quantiques on est en train de mettre au
point peut-être que dans 20 30 ou 40 ou
50 ans on sera nous aussi capable de
voyager dans le temps et nous
comprendrons ce à quoi nous sommes
confrontés on peut s'interroger tout de
même si vous êtes qui sur les Bernard
j'ai ouvert une porte spatio-temporelle
moi aussi Jean-Claude on peut
s'interroger sur les différents
témoignages parce que par exemple qui
vient d'évoquer un cas particulier on
dit que ce sont des petits hommes et là
les Texans vient de dire qu'ils font 2 m
la réponse à la question
sur les dossiers depuis 50 ans il y a
plus il y a plusieurs façons de répondre
très calmement à cette question
intelligente premièrement il n'y a pas
qu'une planète habitée qui nous visite
bien sûr et deuxièmement de la même
façon que chez nous il y a des petits
blancs des grands blancs des petits
noirs des grands noirs des petits jaunes
des grands jaunes et cetera peut-être
que sur cette planète il y a plusieurs
catégories sociales
qui font des milliards de kilomètres ça
doit prendre un certain temps quoi
faut que tu lises le livre supérieur ils
sont super purement intelligents ils
font 2 m 50 des gros yeux ils se pose un
champ quand il y a un pays sans qu'avec
son clébard il se barre pourquoi il
parle
[Applaudissements]
ils sont pas là pour nous attaquer
il m'énerve alors quand on entend ce
genre de connerie genre de de mon ami un
peu plus loin sur cette table on
comprend pourquoi les extraterrestres
hésitent un peu bien sûr
ils sont tellement cons que non mais
c'est vrai je n'irai pas jusque là parce
que j'ai exactement comme lui il y a 50
ans mais je vais lui offrir mon livre et
je pense que après l'avoir lu il y a une
approche de la vérité plus authentique
mais c'est vrai oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a
Gilles est intéressant oui maintenant
les Américains quand même on demandait à
la NASA d'enquêter récemment il y a un
officier de renseignement qui a dit
voilà ce qui se passe donc on a
l'impression que les Américains sont en
train de préparer l'opinion que ça
mondiale au fait nous nous savons
maintenant on va partager savoir avec
vous moi je pense que l'enquête là va
aboutir est-ce qu'on n'est pas au bord
c'est ça ce que dit Gilles est-ce qu'à
un moment il y a des chefs d'État qui
vont dire voilà je vous le dis on n'est
pas seul sur la planète
dire et avec ce que vous venez de dire
donc ça va je pense qu'il n'est pas du
tout normal moi qui est utile depuis
plus de 50 ans qui est cette espèce
d'accumulation incroyable de témoignages
de révélation vous avez les Américains
qui disent on dégage millions de dollars
de plus pour essayer les objets volants
non identifiés il se passe quelque chose
on va le savoir dans les mois
pour rappel à noter les spectateurs il
est 20h56 on en direct il faut rappeler
que dans toutes les grandes puissances
il y a un budget colossal alloué ou même
pas parlé aux extraterrestres aux ovnis
aux objets non identifiés c'est vrai
donc c'est pas pour rien ça c'est pas
pour rien c'est pas pour rien et
notamment les États-Unis qui sont
évidemment leader dans cette affaire
mais les Chinois aussi vous savez mes
livres ont été traduits en chinois et je
me souviens très bien du traducteur
chinois qui parlait évidemment
parfaitement le français qui avait créé
une revue sur les objets volants d'un
identifie en Chine qui était la première
revue privée vendue en Chine bon ils
sont humiliaires 400 millions quand même
bien sûr oui c'est ça qui me dérange et
pourquoi les budgets en fait si ça
existait pas parce que moi je suis
sceptique je vous cache pas je me dis à
chaque fois il se plante en soucoupe ils
atterrissent dans des champs il se
plantent et il y a quelqu'un qui les
croise on sait même pas on n'arrive pas
en serrer un il repart toujours on sait
pas comment il reparle il a planté ça se
coupe mais on les voit ils arrivent
toujours à se barrer on en a pas chopé
un donc je suis sceptique mais pourquoi
les budgets et c'est ça qui me dérange
moi je me dis si ils mettent autant
d'oseille c'est que forcément on nous
cache un truc et je suis pressé moi
aussi
vite vite vite à mon avis comme a dit
Gilles je pense qu'on va pas tarder à
avoir une échelle d'État qui vont dire
voilà on est faite du coup non mais ça
va créer la police il est fatigué mais
ça va créer la peinture sur le dis assis
vous êtes pas du tout paniquer ça vous
fait pas peur du tout moi voilà moi je
me pose la question parce que je lis le
je lis beaucoup ce que c'est écrit
Jean-Claude se faire soigner
gratuitement en France
[Applaudissements]